good evening vanessa well a huge
sigh of relief for the owners here at
this restaurant locale
it's in the southwest valley right near
blue diamond and buffalo now they say
these higher capacity limits starting on
monday
and then again on march 15 are really
just a game changer
moving forward now the restaurant's
owner tells me like many other small
businesses
they've struggled with 25 capacity as
they have a small space here
it's also tough to space tables six feet
apart so six people allowed at tables
starting this coming monday will help
exponentially we were here with locale's
owner andy hooper
the minute he saw governor sisalek make
the announcement his entire team was
pretty happy
a little relieved uh that we didn't stay
at the pause
but uh you know definitely happy that we
went to the sixth person at a table uh
rule but uh you know i would have liked
to have went to 50 but i guess i'll take
the 35 and we'll work with that until
the middle of march
now again as vanessa said restaurants
like locale here can start rio
or start operating rather at 35 capacity
starting on monday
increase the number of people at tables
to six
people again starting on monday then
bump that capacity up
to 50 percent on march 15. another
point that will be helpful for
restaurant owners like this one here
no reservations required again starting
on monday they have been required
through the statewide pause
so really a light at the end of the
tunnel for those here they say they
already
are making plans to add more people
welcome more people to this restaurant
location
safely for now reporting live in the
southwest valley tonight sophomore
office 8 news now